[Music]
Chucky's show with Hal Rudnick oh hi
guys guess what it's Valentine's Day or
slightly after Valentine's Day like
depending on when you're watching this
what did you do for Valentine's Day did
you go on some hot romantic date or did
you stay home and play left for dead
because you feel like the opposite sex
has left you for dead because it's day
of love I started thinking about romance
and romantic movies and how some of the
plots of these movies and scenarios are
really kind of creepy I don't think
they'd work in real life so I contacted
a bunch of women off Craigslist and
brought him down here to find out here's
what happened so uh thanks for being
here thank you for having me just gonna
ask you a couple questions
what's the sweetest thing a guy has ever
said to you that I'm beautiful on the
inside and the out what's the perfect
romantic present something from the
heart that's kind of cheesy is it old
school to believe in love at first sight
I think it's totally old school I don't
think that people believe in as much
these days what's the best pick-up line
you've ever heard hey how's it going hey
how's it going are you gonna say it like
that to me out of our yes have you ever
been in love many times probably eight
eight or nine I'm gonna run some
romantic scenarios by you I'd like you
to close your eyes and picture this
stuff happening and then let me know how
you would react what if I was a really
good dancer and we did a super sexy
dance together
that's definitely sexy what if we did
that dance in front of your parents a
sexy dance in front of my parents very
dirty dance that would be really
uncomfortable for me and then not for me
because I'm Patrick Swayze what if a man
stood outside your window blasting
really loud music to get your attention
who's the guy are you into trenchcoats
no what if he used an old-school boombox
what's the song some Peter Gabriel you
don't know Peter Gabriel do you know who
Peter Gabriel is no yo Peter Gabriel is
no what if a man watched you while you
slept
that would really freak me out what if
he was a vampire then it would be cool
all vampires are stalkers oh you see
Twilight that's all Edward does he just
watches her sleep any stocks are around
you wake up you roll over you see me and
I say hey how's it going no absolutely
not okay what if we had a lengthy
relationship broke up and then I erased
my memory of everything having to do
with you especially like if I was like
epic and sexy just like what do you mean
epic epic astounding stellar I have a
lot of follow-up questions but I will
save them you would have to erase your
memory to get over me cuz I'm just that
cool what do you do that's that cool um
I can't I it was learn and not with my
tongue in ten seconds we get some pull
and peel Twizzlers what if I got to sent
back in time to tell you that a killer
robot is after you and your unborn son
but then while we're on the run we have
sex together and turns out I'm the
father of that unborn son and he's also
the one that sent me back in time what
if I watched you kiss your brother and
then we blew up the Death Star together
that's just weird and I don't actually
know what movie that's from Death Star
Princess Leia and Han Solo oh my god
really I missed that I'm like what okay
yeah awesome and Empire Strikes Back
yeah that was like Natalie Portman right
in Empire Strikes Back what if I
traveled back in time and you fell in
love with me but it turns out I'm your
son and then I set up a plot where I
pretended to violate you and your car I
would not find that romantic what about
the clock tower clock tower 88 miles per
hour
you're pop-culture references lost on me
Doc Brown sounds pretty creepy if it's
your cousin Marvin Marvin Barry back to
the future
nope someone actually went out and got
pulling peeled Twizzlers for you
man you guys are high-end here no we're
not work your magic okay see if I can't
remember how it goes do you know what it
means that you're great at oral sex
actually just means you're a good French
kisser Hallie do you have a Valentine I
do not will you be my Valentine
of course this episode was a success I
don't care what else happens we're good
we're good here well I think we can
safely say that romance is dead okay so
what two movie characters would you want
to see go on a date together and what
would that date look like leave an
awesome answer in the awesome comment
section below and the most awesome
answer gets a screen junkies t-shirt
while we're on the subject of romance I
want to encourage you to check out our
notebook honest trailer it's super funny
wait a second why are you plugging our
most viewed show on a lesser viewed show
shouldn't it be the other way around
get it together screen junkies alright
that's all we got
I'm Hal Rudnick bye-bye